sans frédéric toi alors ailleurs dans le
monde le droit au suicide assisté ou le
droit à l'euthanasie là ça varie selon
les pays
oui en fait dans la plupart des pays du
monde entier c'est un accès qui
n'existent pas alors on va y aller avec
une certaine dégradation par exemple
prenons le cas de la france est
intéressant là bas c'est qu'on ne parle
pas de suicide assisté ou d'euthanasie
mais plutôt de droit à la sédation
profonde et continue alors qu'est ce que
ça veut dire c'est que en cas de
maladies incurables
on peut vous administrez si vous
l'acceptez évidemment un antidouleur qui
est un effet secondaire celui de
d'abréger non seulement la souffrance
mais aussi votre vie c'est très
réglementé c'est assez complet ainsi
complexe pour en profiter il ya ensuite
ce qu'on appelle l'euthanasie passive
quatre exemples ce qu'on voit dans les
pays la suède la norvège l'allemagne et
l'autriche qu'est ce que c'est
l'euthanasie passive et bien c'est ça
permet en quelque sorte de contre et
l'acharnement thérapeutique donc si vous
en avez assez si vous êtes vraiment
atteint d'une maladie incurable que vous
ne voulez plus endurer ce genre de
traitement et bien vous pouvez faire
cette demande donc d'euthanasie passive
évidemment ça prend le consentement du
patient ou si le patient est inconscient
évidemment moment l'acceptation des
proches ou de la famille puis vous avez
bien sur le suicide assisté tel qu'on le
connaît ici ça commençait en fait en
suisse en 1942 qui était le premier pays
à offrir cette option là et ensuite il y
en a une poignée d'états américains qui
ont emboîté le pas par exemple le rig
washington mentana le vermont la
californie le colorado c'est en quelque
sorte ce qu'on appelle l'aide médicale à
mourir encore une fois c'est très
encadré et puis il ya des pays qui s'en
allait plus loin là dans le droit à
l'euthanasie
voilà et là en fait on parle vraiment
dessus de ce qu'on appelle l'euthanasie
active ce sont les pays du benelux le
premier c'était les pays bas en 2001
ensuite la belgique a suivi en 2002 et
le luxembourg en 2009
ce qui est intéressant la base c'est que
vous pouvez faire une demande anticipée
d'accès à l'euthanasie active donc si
vous n'êtes même pas atteints d'une
maladie incurable vous pouvez faire une
demande
et c'est valable pendant cinq ans alors
on va regarder justement en terminant le
cas de la belgique est assez particulier
parce qu'en 2014
on a ajouté une provision à la loi qui
permet à des enfants en fait des mineurs
peu importe leur âge d'avoir accès à
l'euthanasie active il faut l'accord des
parents est également une évaluation du
discernement de l'enfant qui veut
prendre la décision jusqu'ici a eu trois
personnes qui se sont prévalus de ça ce
sont des enfants de 11 13 et 17 ans
enfin si on regarde justement pour
terminer le nombre de déclarations
légales d'euthanasie en belgique on le
voit c'est vraiment exponentielle depuis
2002 entre 2002 et 2010 est il ya 17600
de belges qui ont été jusqu'au bout et
qui ont donc mis fin à leurs jours avec
cette option qui leur étaient proposées
très bien merci beaucoup frédéric y
compris